und jetzt in diesen momenten schickte
uns diese bilder aus einem krankenhaus
aus einem schalter bei einem krankenhaus
wo weiterhin kranke versorgt werden
müssen wo kleine babys geboren werden wo
menschen die eh schon in not sind jetzt
noch in eine viel größere not kommen wir
sehen hier kranke oder kinder oder
mütter die frisch gewährt haben in
diesen gängen in dem krankenhaus müssen
weiterhin versorgt werden und genau dort
ist paul ronzheimer jetzt uns auch
zugeschaltet der uns diese unfassbaren
bilder mitgebracht hat paul schilder uns
einmal was du dort erlebt bei den
menschen die er schon in not sind und
jetzt noch mehr not aushalten müssen
dieser krieg hat dazu geführt dass die
menschen dann wenn das alarm geht hier
unten in den keller flüchtet man sieht
hier die rohre die hier verlaufen und
die patienten sind untergebracht in
diesen zimmern körpers
film endlich hier sieht man wie
patienten warten und wir sehen kleine
babys die hier sind kleine babys
runtergebracht in diesem bunker patricia
heute alleine heute sind sechs babys
geboren worden ein neues leben in einer
situation die schwer zu beschreiben ist
weil es für die menschen hier so
schwierig ist wenn wir uns den krieg
anschauen und was draußen auf den
straßen los ist
paul ehrlich gesagt bei den bildern
fehlen uns hier im studio auch gerade
die worte beschreibt uns mehr wie es den
menschen geht es dieses kleine leben was
dort gerade startet mitten im krieg
mitten in diesem leid was die menschen
dort ertragen müssen wie geht es den
menschen dort wie können sie überhaupt
versorgt werden in dieser situation
ja die versorgungslage die wird versucht
sich hingestellt zu werden durch nur
durch die stadt durch die bürgermeister
durch witali klitschko der sozusagen
weiterhin die logistische
nimmt aber natürlich fehlt es schon an
bestimmten medikamenten teilweise aber
die menschen bei der parade im krieg
sind froh wenn sie vermeintlich sicher
sind wenn sie hier sitzen können im
keller wo sie nicht davon ausgehen
müssen dass
pakete sofort erwischt werden so wie wir
das erlebt haben bei dem fernsehturm wo
mittlerweile die zahl der zumindest noch
fünf angestiegen ist die gestorben sind
und ich sitze hier
alleine zu hause den eltern erzählte
arbeit gelaufen
ich hatte eine explosion gehört eine
große
open window denn die fenster geöffnet
eindruck ist
dass der park des hauses komplett
zerstört wurde
jetzt schon sieben tage hier in einem
keller also da ging es um eine explosion
die nichts mit dem fernsehen schon zu
tun hat sondern mit einer weiteren
explosion das ist ja nicht der erste
angriff gewesen gegen kiel gelaufen
einmal gleich so ein bisschen weiter in
die richtung jorges promi marke wird
indes der action fließt ich zeige euch
mal wie lang sozusagen die sagt keller
ist und wie es hier aussieht sehen hier
in der dunkelheit hinein geschnitten und
ihr dürft nicht vergessen wir sind
patienten untergebracht wir sehen hier
teilweise auch schwangere frauen die
dort auf den boden legen
andere die warten und telefonieren und
versuchen irgendwie durchzukommen und
durch die räume und
das fast endlos hier dieser keller
keinem patricia paul man mag all die
kriegs baby ist dort rausholen mit ihren
müttern aus diesem keller und einfach
nur weg bringen gibt es eine chance dass
die rauskommen aus dieser krieg statt
paul ich glaube vor uns haben hört uns
gerade nicht mehr in diesem krankenhaus
keller in dem wir die babys dieses
krieges sehen die im krieg zur welt
kommen und keine aussicht haben im
moment in einer besseren welt leben zu
dürfen wir versuchen noch mehr zu paul
seidler wer jetzt wieder bei uns
paul ist gerade ja wir sind krankenhaus
dann würde
ja genau ich bin jetzt wieder hier
zurück kehrt denn das ist eines der
neugeborenen aus den letzten stunden
tagen und das baby das muss man sich
vorstellen gerade erst auf die welt
gekommen und lebt schon den krieg her in
der ukraine mit und stellt fällig die
richtige frage möchte diese menschen am
liebsten diese babys sofort einpacken um
sagen raus hier nur tatsächlich bitte
keller immer wird der kessel umkehrt
immer enger es wird immer schwieriger
für zivilisten herauszukommen und viele
sagen uns auch dennoch dass sie ihre
stadt nicht aufgeben wollen weil
wladimir putin wieder angreift sondern
dass die stolzen ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sind und dass sie hier bleiben
jetzt haben wir eben gerade auch den
bürgermeister der stadt gesehene seine
menschen dazu aufgefordert hat sie auch
zuflucht zu suchen weil man vor der lage
in kiew jetzt besonders große sorge hat
zeigt uns einmal wie können die menschen
dort unten versorgt werden gibt es eine
möglichkeit viele haben sind
wahrscheinlich auch auf gewisse hilfe
oben in den krankenhaus zimmern
angewiesen kann man da zwischendrin auch
wieder hoch oder ist man jetzt erst mal
auf unbestimmte zeit dort unten im
keller gefangen
das kommt immer auf die aktuelle lage an
vertriebs ja also man bekommt warnung
auf die handys per app zum beispiel es
gibt
sirenenalarm der tönt und dann gibt es
aber auch wieder entwarnung also ist es
ein stetiges auf und ab gehen in der
nacht allerdings sind die meisten
ausschließliche unten weil dort da
an die gefahr besonders stark ist dass
es eben raketeneinschläge geben gleich
inklusion geben könnte was das nach
draußen gehen angeht ja das ist richtig
man sollte nicht nach draußen gehen die
reporter und müsste das trotzdem um
zu zeigen was in dieser stadt passiert
und zu zeigen was die menschen passiert
aber wir erwarten dass das auch für uns
in den nächsten tagen sehr viel
schwieriger werden könnte wenn die
angriffe intensiver werden sollten noch
du bringst du dass diese bilder paul
ronzheimer die so wichtig sind für alle
da draußen für uns in deutschland in der
welt vielen dank für diese momente dort
in krankenhaus keller alles gute